Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, this week on
Gotham Vigilantes are the coming for everyone
and it’s raining dead bodies.
I don’t know about you guys, but Selina
Kyle and Gordon are my new favorite pairing
next to Oswald and Gordon.
They also just cast Nicholas D’Agosto as
Harvey Dent, which is very cool.
So let’s do top 5 moments, then I’ll do
my review and some updates on Flash and Arrow
at the end.
Careful for spoilers from the episode if you
haven’t seen it yet, I’ll wait just a
sec...okay, here we go
Number 5 - Meet Sal Maroni, one of Gotham’s
Bigger Mobsters
This is the character that Eric Roberts played
in The Dark Knight.
So based on the timeline, we can guess he’ll
only be getting worse from here on out.
He’s being played by David Zayas from Dexter
on Gotham.
It’s fun to watch him being evil.
They’re setting up a big confrontation between
him and Falcone.
I loved the Emperor’s New Clothes reference.
In the episode he said “The Emperor has
no clothes” but you get the idea.
He’s just calling Falcone out as a fool
who can’t see what’s really going on around
him.
At least Maroni believes that, Falcone is
pretty shrewd, so I don’t think Fish Mooney
or any of the other big mob characters will
be able to just dump him in
the bay.
Number 4 - Bruce and Alfred Start To Have
Some Fun
I was glad they finally let the characters
loosen up a little.
Yes Bruce Wayne is a dark character, but that
doesn’t mean he can’t have fun.
He’s still a little kid.
Batman mostly does a lot of punching, but
he does swordfight when he’s fighting villains
that primarily use swords like Ra’s Al Ghul.
It wasn’t subtle at all either, but they
just want use to watch Bruce stuck on the
idea of protecting Gotham...without turning
into a criminal yourself in the process.
We’re only a few episodes into the first
season, so they have to directly set up a
lot of big things like this.
What I’m really hoping to see is an episode
where Bruce actually goes out and tries to
help someone, like if sees someone in trouble
while he’s out in public.
Or see him try to deal with a bully.
Just an instance of him toying with the idea
of piecing together clues and taking action
to solve it.
The Detective bit was a nice nod to Batman
being the World’s Greatest Detective.
Number 3 - The Penguin is on the Rise
I think the speed with which they brought
him back into the city tells you how important
his character is to season 1.
I like that they gave him the tuxedo looking
suit at the end.
It’s all setup for Gordon and Penguin teaming
up to deal with the storm brewing on the Penguin’s
map.
This doesn’t really address the Arkham situation
that much, but that will also be a big part
of this map here soon in the middle.
In the comics, Maroni actually funded Hugo
Strange’s expirements at Arkham Asylum on
the orders of Falcone.
I don’t know that the show will go in that
direction, but Hugo Strange will be part of
the Arkham storyline this season.
Oswald is just going to be like the evil medium
for Gordon that will help him see these connections.
The implication being that Gordon dealing
with these bigger fish will leave room for
Oswald to move in on their territory.
Number 2 - Catwoman and Gordon are on the
case
Definitely my favorite pairing in the episode,
Selina Kyle montages have been the most fun
so far.
Did you notice how they’re letting her give
people the Batman Slip, like she’ll just
appear and disappear as she pleases.
Their field trip was just a continuation of
the Wayne killing.
I know based on the shiny shoes and the way
the story is positioning people there are
a lot of theories about The Penguin being
the one to murder them.
It’s true in the comics, Joe Chill is the
killer, but the show might be doing something
different.
It could be merging those characters.
It’s just that Joe Chill did not wear shiny
shoes in the comics, like he wasn’t a slick
person.
He was just an alcoholic looking for booze
money.
On Gotham, they’re making it seem like someone
with a special attention to style did it,
like say, someone who wears fancy suits and
would be crazy enough to murder the Waynes.
Just something to think about.
Plus I like the implication that the Penguin
will help Gordon put all these huge villains
behind bars, but then Gordon will realize
that his biggest ally is also the person behind
the huge season 1 mystery murder.
Number 1 - Vigilante’s Are On The Rise
More will be coming is probably a phrase they’ll
put on a poster.
It’s also foreshadowing for the rest of
the season.
There will be more vigilantes, mostly violent
ones.
I’m hoping we get a Red Hood easter egg
at some point.
There are a lot of negative Batman vigilantes.
Like flat out crazy ones.
But supposedly the show has cast Sara Paxton
as Bette Kane, one of the characters to take
on the mantle of Bat Girl in the comics.
She used to be listed on the show’s IMDB
page, but she’s not there anymore, so it’s
possible they cut her out of the pilot or
they’re not doing her character anymore.
But I do think the show will bring on actual
Batman Vigilante characters from the comics
this season.
Just people that Bruce Wayne can point to
as inspiration for better or worse.
For the most part, Gordon is really the only
good vigilante type person on the show for
now.
He’s supposed to be the benchmark for hero.
Let me know, what was your favorite moment
and which vigilante’s do you want to see
on the show next?
There was the whole Barbara Kean Montoya Drug
Storyline.
I’m not sure what they’re doing with those
characters.
I ended up giving the episode a B overall,
just because I feel like the ending completely
threw away the Montoya scene.
That was all about creating a wedge between
Gordon and Barbara, but then Barbara totally
buys Gordon’s explanation.
No he would never kill someone, and to pour
salt in Montoya’s wound, the Penguin walks
through the door, looking like a million bucks.
That’s about as far from dead as you can
get.
So my big question is what the heck are they
trying to do with Montoya?
It feels like they were trying to give some
more dimension to the Barbara Kean character
by making her a former drug addict and bisexual,
but they completely undercut it at the end.
So I’m a little confused as to where both
those female characters are going.
My favorite performance in the episode was
Camren Bicondova again, I feel like this is
a show that wants you to know it’s a comic
book Dick Tracy looking show.
Like this is a Dick Tracy type environment,
so the characters are supposed to act in a
comic book-y way.
And Camren is just having fun with it, like
she should.
Some of the other actors look like they’re
taking it a little seriously like Ben McKenzie.
So I’d like to see him have a little more
fun with it.
The Bullock Gordon montage was pretty awful,
I like montage storytelling, but the music
they used felt very out of place and I just
wasn’t buying it.
So only big issues were the montage and Montoya
with Barbara, otherwise, very fun episode.
Next up this week is The Flash, episode 1
is airing tomorrow.
I’m going to try and get a few more bonus
videos out before then.
Arrow episode 1 is on wednesday.
I’m probably going to combine my Q&As for
those shows.
I won’t be doing a Gotham Q&A tomorrow just
because of all that stuff, but there will
be extra flash and arrow videos.
Right now click here to learn about some of
the Flash villains and click here for last
week’s Gotham Episode.
Thanks for watching, everybody high five and
I’ll see you guys tomorrow!